Well, the idea of this application as such
s to know
ow much devel
pment can be given to a program that
s made, how much scope
has shiny as a game to cr
ate, apply the active appointments that appea
on the web in general and which ones could
say what is its limit in
development and if it is good
if it has it because I think that I
really believe in the limit of an application
in saint and it gives it the same imagination of
the people
as I was saying I would like to start
talking about the step  step by step of the
development that there was in this application
[Music]
of the challenges that there were because there were
quite a few done so
I think it is a good way to know
how is the general development of an
application as it is above all the
contamination and integrate other
tools such as  they are the html
widgets, especially widgets based on
packages from javascript and that can
be very interactive.
I would like to start by telling you and
commenting on which c  What was the
objective of this application, well in this
case the objective was simply to see the
limit that this wave has, the scope it
has to be able to create an
application and this, in fact, this
application emerged in an
interesting way because in the last two
years it has been in  creating applications
for me has become like my daily bread
it has been like a hobby more than
anything
and I am me and I have always been like
trying to search what else can I do is
find
some data on the internet or something
like that information  The official statistics
of, for example, the government,
things like that can be
built little by little with a little
creativity above all
and with this one day if I
was simply on the page of giving python in my
song with an interesting application
that spoke  about these issues
so
then that's when I asked myself the
question
will it be possible to do it in the
same application but nr and with that it
occurred to me b  ok and I'm going to download the
data I'm going to I'm going to start working
with the information and let's see to what
extent I can create an application
like that or even improve it now that it was
achieved with it simple with this
application the general idea was to
create a  program that could visualize
absolutely all the data of
uber
dv in new york city for an
entire month
the idea that you could filter the
information by guide by
visualizing certain areas and even that it
could visualize certain, especially
hours of the day,
this so that  outside as a very
interactive and very simple way to understand
more or less what are the
hours of greatest density of trips in
moving, for example, the areas with the greatest
density, you can see this very
simply on a map, you can see it
on a bar graph in  a program
for example and this was where the
first challenge began because when I downloaded
the information there were like 600 thousand
observations here it was there  i would have a
string for the date
we had the date and time so the
idea was how can i split into hours
and dates so
this is where my first
ideas started here i had two ways to do it i
could use the one law for a
wonderful patina for for  be able to
work with dates, but I'm going to
try something else that will seem a
little faster to compile in the
language
and I think it was a little more interesting
to apply, which was to take that string of
characters and convert it into two
separate ones, one of which was the  time of the day
that was also another challenge because
I had to use a conditional function
to be able to separate that because that time
was not in a good state also in
minutes, so separate as certain
periods of the day to
see that all of this
data is already there  one in the afternoon for
example at 2 in the afternoon and that and on the
other hand separating for the dates that
was much simpler just
by applying the function  On a sub front of
the base language, with that, it can be
very simply the separation by
date and now, starting with the date,
you can filter the information
about ok and on this day there were so
many many trips on this other day there were
so many others
and to  Starting from that, seeing on this
same day the trips had a higher
density at a certain time, for example,
at two in the afternoon it could have been the
time with the highest density. I mean, it is an
example, I did not recognize it right now,
but it is an example,
so here  a little
more creativity started it was how am I going to start
the application
for this there are very simple ways
to do it but
I think
well in fact we have many libraries
to do it as well as
html widgets
but I get by using mostly
html and css code because  it is
a much more
flexible
and much better non-dynamic rather
much more
interactive way to do this
now a good question is did it exceed
expectations  initials this application
is good for that I think that the correct thing
would be to visualize both applications and
that each personality their verdict
about them then if
something more interesting was achieved or if
not if it
appears from the perspective of other
people there was the original application it was
better  I think that this is already more a
matter of d
because it must prescribe to each
person's staff, so if you want that
later and we are going to compare now
another very important thing that I want to
comment on and what I want to start
this talk with is the structure of  the
application because here this although it does not
seem from the most important parts
and above all what I usually use a
lot is to separate the files that is the
wii the server and the global basically the
global file what it does is load
all the libraries all the objects
that luigi is going to be used
is simply the customization
that one as a user sees
the output of the images of the
graphs of the te  xtos that there are for
example the logos the logos the
images etcetera
and the server is where all the information is compiled
and what I usually use the reason
why I usually separate these files
more more than more than for a
compilation time or that  I usually do it more
than anything as a matter of order
because it is much easier to be able to
identify certain codes or certain
parts of the application if you have it very
directed, very sectioned, than that also
when they are already very large applications,
also in my opinion it is highly recommended
use modules although that is already a
bit more
complicated at first but it is very useful
in the long
term okay now
what can be done with the application
as you can see on the right side we have
the original fiction of planning life and
on the left side my version in  at
hayling the idea was to make something that looks
very interactive and that and try to
enhance it visually
and try to make something that will be
even more noticeable.  It's simply that it was self-
explanatory,
for example
in the application of these they use a
palette of bile colors, it seems to me in
this case I preferred to use a
color palette that is based on the
colors
yellow, red and blue because it seemed
to me that it was like more  simple to identify
yellow colors for the 10th hours
plus
the first hours of the day
red colors for noon and
blue colors for the night I feel that it
is a simpler and more self-
explanatory way of
understanding the hours of density of
trips in  instead for that part try to
improve it especially also give a
better visualization to the map for this
or I simply moved it in a certain
scale so that if I break it with some
columns with some codes so that it
will serve as a little more in three
dimensions that it will not be  just like
a
static map or a map that
looks like a canvas I think it looks like
something more
alive to look at
now on the  customization of the
application that there is that was already something
simpler simply ordering names
put a logo a logo that
my applications use a lot I think I
'm going to start patenting the y
and here I simply use a
color palette that was as a chord change
the background  make it look
nice to look at
so that anyone who came in would see it and say ok
ok this is about this is interesting I'm going
to get the information very well now
about the parts of the application
you know we have the inputs the
cars imputed them  In general, they are the buttons, they
are the ones that you select the day, time,
etc., and the outputs are what
the application returns when you fill in
after certain information, for example, in
this case, it is filtered
by filtering the zone, the time, the day,
above all, and that really  that at
first is like a bit complicated to
apply because
because the applications as such
are sometimes not very intuitive
regarding how to apply  r an input and
an output
and these are things that are learned
little by little and they are things that after
a certain time become quite
intuitive
but in my opinion they are things that
require a lot of practice currently I
think that
using applications and sometimes it is
even  easier than just going
to the deere console and filtering and removing the
filter function for example from the
player to filter information
like much faster to grab take I
don't know a
certain function grab create create a
data frame a vector rather
with the data you want to filter and
with that, you simply select
with a button, it seems to me to be much
simpler and much more intuitive
for people, I think this is more than
anything as a visual result that would
go to the end user  especially
for people who do not have much
programming knowledge I think this
is very useful
and of course not to program it yes not to
show it to people about  Everything
now, as I was telling you a moment ago
, customizing the application as such is
something simple and there are many libraries
to do this, such as sleep, jane, and
widgets, but I think that the ideal and most
optimal thing is to use html and css, and this is
because I say it because  that is the language
on which these libraries are based to
make the contamination of the application
simply those libraries the only thing they
do is encode certain
html codes or certain colors or certain sizes
figures in functions of functions that
you can apply since January I think  that
the best thing in this case is you directly
apply those html codes for example
to give forms to give spaces and the
css codes to control
source colors etc.
that's why I say that this is an optimal way
to be able to work that information that
beauty seen is  con is directly
applying the original code to do
that is like a
more caste way of doing it could be said now
starting  Or to talk about the
html widgets applied, for example,
in noticed that the most common package that
uses the one they usually use to
create slipher maps in, in my opinion, is
an excellent package because it has other
sub-packages that teach you
other ways to customize it.  They
include, for example, a minimap within
the mini-graphics mode within the map
and gender is
excessively customizable. In this case,
what I wanted was for it to be much
faster to compile, that it will not take long to
load the map, so for that I used
the javascript library  mac box which in
this case has a compiler nr
called boxer is a very good library
what I like a lot about this
library specifically is that it loads
the information too quickly in
this case we can see for this and
specifically we have
about  50 also travel and we can see that
it takes practically nothing to make your
move away approach go to certain areas and
that and that's what  What I love about this
library is that when you directly
do
high filtering or do something like that, it does it
practically in real time and that
seems incredible to me that the user can
have something extremely simple and
see it very quickly because I think
that also  It is a very important part
of an application that works fast and
because we not only know what functions are fast
by compilation, but also because it is more
pleasant for users, hardly
someone who sees a page that takes a
long time to load, for example, is going to
stay and analyze  the information, but in
this case, since it works very
quickly, it is very likely that he will begin to
play with the information and begin to
see everything more thoroughly,
then now for the graphs, in this
case, a program that was used in, for
this I chose to use  charts which is a
javascript library of hash charts
that what it does is generate interactive charts
that can also have,
for example, a
label  These are extremely
customizable. In fact, if they got
into it like that, they go to see its
official documentation. It's like 200
pages of a shell.
Now another thing that I like a lot
about this package is that it's not
only very fast to compile, but
it's also  very nice visually and I think
that it
also
has codes that are very simple to
understand, for example, country, initialize
a graph and use the function and
graphs, and with that you simply write
and line, for example, to make an
olive grove line, to make a bar art, and
establish in this  good case, of
course, those are the
functions that were integrated
into his developer with whom he
developed this package directly
so that
the good script with which I thank him
very much because he has created
very interesting packages that I have
used quite well  I think that this is
an advantage of this library,
apart from the fact that it is a custom isable that is
very pleasing to the eye.  a is actually very simple
to use and what I
like is that you don't have to spend a lot of
time understanding
the codes but with this you can
spend more time flying your
imagination and thinking about how I can
customize the graph I'm
making how to prune  the best aspect
another interesting challenge is how am I going to read
the information in a fast way
since we have
a good base, a table with 600,000
data for example
and that and besides how am I going to filter
it quickly since the one I have read
considering  Of course, it is a
huge database and the thing is that we have
several alternatives to the weeks
and xvii units, for example,
to the functions to filter be player.
In this case, I opted to use
the data table package because it is
extremely fast, although it is also  there is
the option of the brum package with the
function of the same name that compiles that
when it comes to press even
larger data and tends to complicate it, it tends to
read a little  or faster for this case
as there were 600 and observations I think it
was enough where with fast with as a
negative
but it was not enough we need an
alternative to be able to read the
information very quickly in this
case use good use and player
but it does not mask it with  the
dt player functions that what it does is use
the data table syntax to be able to
increase the speed of the
player functions which says that the application
works precisely in real time
this made it much faster when
loading much faster
when  starting at the beginning that
practically made the application fly and it will
work in real time that there are no
waiting lines to be able to simply
filter a day or they filter an hour for
example that is what is a
recommendation that I would always give to
create an application in January
that  applications always try to
find
an alternative to libraries that
can give you greater speed because  It is
a very important part, in my opinion, of
the appointment of data analysis and
statistics after visualizing that
information very quickly because if you want to
do another type of analysis you
need to necessarily have a
high speed in reading and
writing the information and  also in
the
for example in the creation of a new
variable or
or when you create groups to section the
information for example
if it is very similar yes it is very important
that you have
a high speed in reading the
information
now simply some
bibliographic references of well of the
of the libraries used their
official documentation and some
some references used for
when I started to use shiny as
a way to create web applications, well
thank you very much for your time
in this talk and well now as a last
point I would like to show you a little about the
application created
the final result in real time
that in my opinion how they can  see it
works now that what works
quite quickly for example we can
filter a certain day we can select an
area and thus we can see the
information for example for the
new york airport
another thing that the application has is that
you can filter work' that goes
saying very
clearly the hours that you have
selected in the histogram
[Music]
and that they swept you to the points that you have
for example
the points that you have on the map here you
can see ok for example
those in the morning
as you can see  they are the yellow dots
or those at noon
and those red dots meet the night that
's what I was telling you it's a very
interactive way of seeing the information and
a very nice way that the point from
this is that people feel comfortable
analyzing apart from  this you can see
information at the end of
now with higher density of trips was
for example in this case the seven the
number of hours selected was
the number of hours that  and we
currently have 8 selected and the
total number of trips for this case
was ten thousand eight hundred dgt for
this day and for the selected hours
well in this case I think it would be
all my presentation I hope you
liked the application that we have
motivated you to  in case one day you want to
start creating web applications or if you
want to
get into this world
of data visualization that I think is
very, very wonderful and has
practically unlimited potential
and you want to leave a question to the
Leos if you
want a recommendation  let it be
hello unfortunately from many ph
presentations most of the
brilliance is to say to those that the
participants if they want to put a
question in fire or that in fact they already put
the brown series in the chat but also
if they wanted to remove mine they can talk  and
asking is asked before you
directly
many times
good for the moment and hands
raised
and if you want
fernando can  and start
how are
you I congratulate you it
is very beautiful
thanks for all the tips
very good points
what I wanted to ask you was
with the glory point you do not because
I have a little time they will be using
the air for about four months I have a
fairly large application and they have been about
five  a thousand lines of things is
relatively large but what I do
to read all my files and upload them
to the application and new ones at first
never use a comb in a global point
where can I find I don't know tutorials
I don't know if you have them on your page
what benefits does the global point have from
reading the files there to having them on
the server? It's
good. I think that more than anything there, the
key point is that you have a greater
order in the application, not so much because
of the loading speed because it
will practically be the same.  where they put the files
what I would recommend is
so that they find the training much
easier or if you want I don't know maybe
review a certain file and it is  or that you
find it much easier that is
why I only divide it into sections
so that you do not get so confused at the
end and especially in your case that
you already have many lines of code because
it would be very useful to divide them as
in sections so that it is easier to
go down to the brain to the
global equal that is already as a matter
of order
now mls get infected hello jorge thanks
for the presentation
I wanted to ask you exactly how
we can use you player we need
to learn the syntax of
facebook data edit and 2 exactly how it works
don't understand thanks that's
the wonderful thing about the package you don't
need is really to learn the
data table syntax you just
write the name of the two
player libraries andy type aller and what it does is
just  it is in the last one is to
mask the functions of player to
use and practically all you
have to do is write the same
functions of the player  r and with that it is
going to increase the speed and
as soon as you decide to filter the
information or work with the
information
that is what I like a lot about that
package in fact
and thanks to you
I don't know if anyone else has any
questions  or any comment
recommendation
in the chat
if the code is available if you want
I'll share it with you in the chat
[Music]
in a second on the podium available
to practice or if you want to replicate
what you want
freddy godoy apparently has a question
hi  time
between a little late and I don't know but
for me it has scared me to use a little
sainz and no but it's because I don't know if you have
to use this or have knowledge
rather of html css
this and all those
web elements that I don't know what  It overwhelms me a little I
really liked your presentation and the
interactivity that this
excellent one presents there but you also have to have
knowledge of these elements
of web programming,
in reality it is not that necessary  Seriously,
I used them in this case because they were
a way that I really wanted to give it
a very specific aspect in
certain areas of the application, for
example,
a certain space in the titles or a
certain space
in the spaces between
buttons.  but although it is necessary to
learn it because
the application directly
since they encode all that code in html,
for example when you use the function
with page suite that already generates all
the video codes
or html codes to be able to generate a
page a blank canvas for  example
in this case and when instead of
using a day to create
222 columns you only use the
color function and give it a wii dybala of
it seems to me that it is a number from 1 to 12 and
with that it is enough I think that to
begin  you need to see practically
nothing of html css is more like and when
you want how to play these very
specific aspects of the escrow
ok perfect thank you very much
and
pablo it seems to me that you have u  no question
pablo efe
and good morning jorge thanks for the
presentation good afternoon for me
a question I didn't hear you
say anything about data security throughout the presentation
I mean the
possibility or better said the impossibility that
the data is made public if one
would like to work
in a more restricted environment or
something like that even if the application is
this one it is open could you
tell me something in that sense if it is
implementable given that strategy that
El Salvador has designed on the one hand on the
other  aside the images in short a bit
as if you have planned it
or if it is possible thanks
in fact if it is possible well
directly the applications because
when you upload to jane they are already in an
ssl security certificate but well
that is another topic but if you  you want,
for example, I don't know how to create an application
that is directly for your company that
is for internal use for
very restricted information or that is a report, for
example  you can create one with, for
example, the train and manager library,
you can create, you can create a layer of
passwords so that only
people you authorize can access this
information,
another thing you can do is, for
example, instead of pulling the information
from a
csv or excel file, for example, you
can pull those from sql is another option
that is more secure plus a little more
restricted, you could say,
but if it is possible to create an application
that is secure, for example, in a
work environment,
hello, now there is a question in  the chat
someone wants to ask if there is any
restriction to use the grape ipi
well
it seems to me that
the query limit for the v api
is
not sure the truth I would lie to
you if the rapporteur told you and that is exact but it
seems to me that it is
one hundred thousand per day I think however good
for the use of this application the
information ends up downloading from an
ssb file so
but
it seems to me that
the restriction to use  the uber api
is very very lax you can download a lot of
information very quickly
thanks only to you
and another question
if jorge how is he so good because a
very very short and very open question
I want to venture into the world of
sainz and for a long time  some time for x10
eta reasons I haven't been able to so I know
good I didn't have who I think it is and I
wanted to ask you about some
recommendations for someone new
documentation for someone new
I think that
I think that the important thing should be there
more than starting with a course or  start
or with tutorials that's good if you need
tutorials to start but what I
recommend more than anything is to practice
everything every day if it is something that requires a lot of
practice above all
and another thing that is very
complicated at first a little
strange to understand is that  as the as
are arguments that go inside the
functions and more functions then there are going to
be many, many parentheses
within the application and that  Well, it's a
bit confusing, so it's something else than
also how to practice a lot,
see how
within the parentheses that you don't miss out
on commas in the application because if
not, it's probably going to run you, so
it
's practically practicing, that's
what  In my opinion, what spends the most what
helps the most for, well, to
improve little by little and create
larger, more complex explanations,
another thing is that when you use it, you
use an argument of some function
and give it a useful and separate the
question mark before  of the of the argument
of the function then it will give you the
it will not give you as tips of that function
all the documentation that the 90 results
from the times it gives a code of ours is
you can copy it and see
how the syntax works as  how
the program works in general
and with that you can gradually get an idea
of how it works and how and how y
u can work on it how you c
n learn from all those dynam
cs perfe
t  thank you very much jorge to you
to interpret the chat in the code you
use the gdp instead of the typical one of
the player this is because of the library you
use no
what happens is that it is the country that I
use that
is the native country deere that simply
me  it seems in version 4.1 I'm not
sure but
later elevation 4 was used and yes,
it is also more a matter of
comfort and taste in my case I
like the native pipe better but you can
continue using the original country the
one used by the  percentage signs
work exactly the same
you just have to go to the global options and
write and select the option to
use the original stick that is already a
matter of taste
I don't know if I have
another question
as a personal recommendation on me but
we must go one step further  at the time you
recommended me first learn html css
javascript i'm in it's cultivated either i
don't know any of the other three
well i would recommend you start
with
html and css because  it is that javascript
is not so necessary to learn
or rather it is more than anything to
use libraries that are very
interactive, for example the map
that took you from one place to another or the
graph that was simply drawn in
time  real those levels based on java
script which is more or
less the advantage of that language
as very visual and very
interactive things but it is more like a
tool that you could implement
when you already want to do something very
interactive but it is not so necessary at the
beginning  when you start
to learn to use
let's say html css sorry you use it
as for the nice part of the
javascript application only for us
but thanks to the interactivity if
right
here
hello I asked who came to me
directly and nothing else for someone
wants to know  the
processing capacity wants to send up that is to
say there is a minimum of memory from go
by companies to dor especially what you
need
I
think that already depends a bit on the context
of the application, for example,
if you use an application that
because what it does is that it takes a certain
part of your ram memory to be able to
load all that information, but it
also does that when you load them in the
server
for example of liniers also so that they
work with a certain fluidity it still takes as
much ram memory from your computer in
this case I think that the best thing would be to
have a computer with 8
gigabytes of ram that really is like the
standard right now but it is more  that is
enough to load very
large information also in terms of processors
it is not necessary to have a
powerful processor but it is recommended it is
really like for example a
tenth generation core i3 or not even from
eighth generation the application would be very fluid
and so  I want to give it too much
power because it is a core i7, an
m1 chip from a brand, something like that
and many classes about
you
i
[Music]
if there are no more questions
[Music] I
could well I don't know if there is anything else you have
any questions recommendation
I don't think so
and to close the session good morning it
dominates you ms candle I work with the fact that it
doesn't already exist thank you very much Jorge
with the presentation the  recording will be
available on the youtube page
abroad and thank you all very much for
meeting us thanks to you
for inviting me it was a great pleasure
no
[Music]